[Music]
teresa's in boston mass hey teresa
what's up in your world
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure
how can i help um my quest my question i
think is more for dr deloney
um my husband and i have been working
you know for years and years and years
and working two jobs getting ahead
getting things done
and just how can we
be okay with seeing all the people
taking the unemployment
people taking the government payoffs and
not just covered stuff but
for years we see this going on
it's frustrating um it's hard
you know when we're just working and
doing it all on our own and we see
essentially kind of freeloaders all
around us
sir you asking me i will tell you
i mean adjust my attitude yeah i'll tell
you what i tell my five-year-old
daughter
when she comes and says hank her older
brother
is doing this and this and that and this
and i tell her
josephine you take care of you
ta-da any decision to look into someone
else's world or situation
and choose to let your perception of
their world
impact your day as a choice that you are
choosing to poison your day hoping that
they get sick from it
and i wish it was more difficult than
that it's a choice is it frustrating to
think and fantasize about what they're
not doing or what their life situation
is or why they are or not
yeah it feels good and it feels in it
you know it's a righteous indignation
right it feels good
yeah but the truth is the the freeloader
stats and all this kind of
you don't know what their world is it's
just an imagination is it frustrating to
have taxes taken out oh my gosh it's a
beating i hate it
and it is and when i drive on a road and
with a pothole on it i want to get into
all that stuff is me choosing to have a
less good
day and so what i would tell you the
same thing i tell josephine is
you take care of you and if you and your
husband decide to wake up tomorrow and
start
looking for where you are driving on
roads you didn't build and when police
officers that you didn't hire show up to
your house and it
you can look for things to be positive
about
or you can let this thing just bury you
so theresa i um suffer from exactly the
same illness
it pisses me off i'm with you
i'm with you okay i don't like it uh
to john's point i had to make a decision
a few years ago so
i by getting in the business that i'm in
and getting up in the spotlight and
everybody have an opinion about me now
um it made me less intense about having
an opinion about other people
[Laughter]
because everybody's pissed off about
something i'm doing all the time i'm
just telling you okay
i can't wear the right shirt i can't
live in the right house i can't vote the
right way i can't say the right thing
i'm not christian enough i'm too
christian
i mean there's something all the time
somebody's bitching about when it comes
to old dave
and so what that helped me with was i
thought i just realized um
you know what it's none of their
business and so me worrying about these
other people is none of my business
and it helped me to kind of go i'm not
going to spend all my time being one of
those guys
because they're cut all those guys are
coming at me twitter trolls and whatever
else right and so i'm
you know i just thought you know i'm
gonna spend all my time
lifting things up adding value that's
right and
less time being mad but but my nature's
to do exactly what you're talking about
kiddo i don't disagree with you but it
helped me to get
pounded by people doing the same thing
towards me that's right
help me to go i'm not doing that anymore
it takes too much of my energy